ich würde begrüßen wenn die schulen
wieder langsam geöffnet werden für
gewisse alterstufen und auch
kindergärten damit eltern die jetzt zu
hause ihre kinder pflegen halt wieder
zur arbeit gehen können ich wünsche mir
halt dass das noch weiterhin diese
einschränkung eingehalten denn dass die
leute auch noch abstand halten und
vielleicht hat dass die kindergärten so
leicht gelockert werden wie das die
eltern entlastet sind also ich war
lehrer ich muss ihnen sagen ich kann mir
das nicht so vorstellen wie sich die
leopoldina das wohl denkt dass da die
schulen sehr schnell wieder öffnen
ich glaube dass allein nur 15 kinder pro
klasse kommen in der regel sind 30
kinder oder über 30 in einer klasse das
wird schwierig umzusetzen in der praxis
ich hoffe es ist die kinder zur schule
da ist die kleine land geschäfte
aufmachen denn ich finde dass
besonders bedroht sind gerade eine krise
und klar geht das schulen fitnessstudios
leicht meine forderungen oder meine
wünsche werden dass das alles mit
augenmaß an geregelt wird in der zukunft
und nicht einfach nur pauschal für alle
das gleiche gilt zuerst fertig es
angebracht wenn der friseur mal wieder
auf hat das man halt nicht zu fünfter
rein kann sondern vielleicht nur einer
oder dass man mal wieder eine boutique
eröffnet wo achter nur eine rein darf
weil wenn man zum bäcker darf mit einem
dann darf man auch zudem finde ich eine
husumer kaufen man muss ja nicht mit
zehn leuten in dem geschäft drin stehen